جنوب افريقيا لا اي من الدول العربيه
والاسلاميه هي التي تقاضي اسرائيل امام
محكمه العدل الدوليه بتهمه ارتكاب جرائم
اباده جماعيه ضد الشعب
الفلسطيني تتلخص القضيه وفق ما صرحت به
محكمه العدل الدوليه في ادعاء جنوب
افريقيا بان اسرائيل انتهكت اتفاقيه منع
الاباده الجماعيه عبر ارتكابها اعمالا
تهدف الى التطهير العرقي في قطاع
غزه واذ توحي هذه الدعوه بما يعتبره
كثيرون هوانا عربيا امام وحشيه الحرب على
غزه فانها تحيل في الوقت نفسه الى تفسيرات
داله في شان هويه الجهه
المدعيه انها جنوب افريقيا التي رزحت
طويلا تحت نير نظام فصل عنصري طالما وصف
بانه شديد الشبه باسرائيل قبل ان يتفكك
بفعل كفاح شعبها اوائل تسعينيات القرن
الماضي لتقام على انقاضه دوله جديده
بزعامه نيلسون مانديل الذي كان قد انهى
للتو 27 سنه من الاعتقال في سجون
الابارتايد والتقى بعد ايام من تحرره
الرئيس الفلسطيني انذاك ياسر عرفات ليؤكد
معا على تشابه كفاح شعبيهما من اجل الحريه
في السياق نفسه و برغم اعتراف جنوب
افريقيا باسرائيل منذ تاسيسها فان
العلاقات بينهما تراجعت عقب تفكيك نظام
الفصل العنصري حتى بلغت حد قيام بريتوريا
بخفض تمثيلها الدبلوماسي في تل ابيب الى
مستوى مكتب اتصال بدلا من سفاره ردا على
قرار الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب
نقل سفاره بلاده الى القدس بينما كان حزب
المؤتمر الحاكم قد استضاف من قبل وفدا من
قياده حركه حماس برئاسه رئيسها السابق
خالد
مشعل لا غرابه اذا في ان تتحرك جنوب
افريقيا على مسار قانوني دولي ضد اسرائيل
بعدما قتلت هذه الاخيره ما يزيد على 23 ال
فلسطيني وجرحت نحو 60 ال اخرين فضلا عن
تدميرها مقومات الحياه في قطاع غزه اطلع
ما احلاها اطلع اطلع لكن اثبات جرائم
الاباده التي يتابعها العالم كله على
الهواء مباشره قد يستدعي معركه قانونيه
طويله ومعقده من جهتهم يقول قانونيون
اسرائيليون ان على جنوب افريقيا ان تثبت
نيه الاباده لدى اسرائيل وتقدم امثله على
اجراءات ميدانيه تعززها في حين يرد
قانونيون متعاطفون مع الفلسطينيين بايراد
تصريحات لوزراء في حكومه نتنياهو كانوا
تحدثوا علنا عن محو غزه وتسويتها بالارض
وقطع الماء والكهرباء والغباء عنها
بالتوازي مع حمله عسكريه غير مسبوقه ثمه
من يحذر هنا من ان المرافعات والمرافعات
المضاده التي ستشهدها محكمه العدل الدوليه
قد تنقل الاباده الجماعيه من حيز الحقائق
المرئيه على الهواء مباشره الى حيز الجدل
في شان تكييفها قانوني يقال هنا ايضا ان
هذا هو ما قد يفسر التحول في استراتيجيه
اسرائيل القديمه وقبولها المثول هذه المره
امام قضاه لاهاي بعدما كانت رفضت عام 2004
حضور اجراءات التقاضي بشان جدار الفصل في
الضفه الغربيه ثم تجاهلت الحكم النهائي
متبرعه بعدم اعترافها بسلطه المحكمه لذلك
تعالت الدعوات في اوساط سياسيه وقانونيه
فلسطينيه وعربيه وعالميه الى ضروره ان
تتخذ محكمه العدل الدوليه في مستهل
انعقادها قرارا احترازيا ينص على وقف
الحرب على غزه بوصفه اولويه اولى لا ينبغي
تاجيلها الى ما بعد حسم الجدل المتوقع في
شان تصنيف او تعريف الجرائم الاسرائيليه
بيد ان اتخاذ قرار كهذا سيحتاج الى تاييد
ثمانيه على الاقل من قضاه المحكمه البالغ
عددهم 15 يمثلون 15 دوله وهو ما قد يكون
متعذرا الا اذا بذلت الدبلوماسيه
الفلسطينيه والعربيه جهدا مسبقا لاحداث
تعديلات على خريطه المواقف وذاك اضعف
الايمان الذي يتمنى الضحايا في غزه بان لا
يكون هو الاخر
متعذرا